hello and welcome to this video on game
12 of the World Championship match
between magnus carlsen defending world
champion and sega kayaking the
Challenger from Russia you notice that
is gained this video is not that long
and jerm this basically already tells
you how this ended because you're not
going to expect someone to blunder a
piece and in like five moves or
something so I'm going to ya go through
this game and let's let's see what
happened that's no surprise we had the
Berlin before and what did we get now
castles bush that's the first part taken
whoosh second pawn bush night whoosh
whoosh two rooks bush bishop bush night
bush clean you're looking for more
wishes here's the next one I'd hear they
agree to it wrong isn't that the most
exciting game ever you've seen if it is
you have a problem in your chest because
this is the most boring game ever yeah
so what to make of this and I was really
thinking that Magnus would try something
with white even though we have to say if
we look at the whole match the white
pieces did not prove to be anything
special for both players um it's
basically a non-game this line here of
the Berlin this line with rookie one
Bishop f1 has the reputation of being
extremely tame and I think it's one of
the one of the drawbacks of this opening
for black cami
the Berlin ending is actually I think
somewhat interesting to play but this is
like the most boring stuff ever so it's
not great not great for the spectators
not great for the guys and I enter
screens and it also especially bad for
those who paid good money to watch the
final game like right in the audience in
new york and from a match point of view
I can do understand the decision to not
make a big fuzzy ball and go to the tie
breaks cars and probably thinks is the
favorite in this which is probably true
still I think and there was no harm in
at least trying to play a game I mean
just like play 30 minutes and then make
a draw it's kind of lame um okay it
doesn't help i'm continuing in this
sendas in this way you probably agree
anyway it's just not not a good way of
yeah making make make shirts look like
you're an interesting and popular sport
if in the final and some of the size of
game nothing happens so we get into
overtime and the tiebreak is going to
plate on wednesday and this is going to
be tense really tense we will have four
rapid games and possible blitz games
after that so it never happened that we
got to the blitz games we had those
tiebreaks an earlier one championship
matches Kramnik to power off from Ligue
1 that that rapid tie-break two wins one
loss are not be galfond i think he had
one win and three drawers I'm not
entirely sure not quite sure but they
didn't get to the blitz either so at
least we can look forward to to the tie
breaks the tie breaks will be very
tensed everything is on the line in just
like a couple of hours so yeah I'm going
to cover this of course as well and yeah
look forward to see those tens
games there probably will be more
spectacular than most of the games that
we have seen in the in the actual
long-term control event okay guys sorry
for having no content damn thanks for
watching